Wordsworth said in the Lake District
that it was the loveliest spot that man
hath found Tim Farron whose seat this is
might have a special reason to agree
it's the closest thing the Lib Dems have
these days to a stronghold but is he as
safe as he seems
he's now remainder in chief but many of
his constituents don't share his
enthusiasm I've exchanged my usual
wheels for something more practical to
talk to one of them farmer Nick Buckley
do you feel sort of personally annoyed
with him that he's he's so pro remain yo
he's you're in a little bit it does
annoy me especially the social media you
know you read a lot of things on social
media these days you know and it's
always pushing for as a second second
referendum and it's like no the
decisions been made now Tim let's I said
buckle down and get on with it and you
know we need to need to make the best of
it we can sir really sir yeah by hook or
by crook by hook or by crook
yes one of the secrets of this election
are the Lib Dem leavers and there are
some about a quarter of all Lib Dem
voters in 2015
voted out in 2016 if the toys could
absorb those they might stand a chance
but Farren's majority is big over 9,000
look Farren should be able to hang on
with the majority that he's got in this
seat but I am told the Tories are going
to target it why well of course you have
the Copeland by-election which took
place just down the road which they won
but also they think that if they can pin
him down here you won't be causing
mischief for them in other seats they're
worried about up and down the rest of
the country reunite it with my trusty
lorry on the Bowness ferry grexit Utes
large with the voters why liberal
because we're Pro Europe in both of us
yeah the same way have you always voted
liberal
no no no so you're moving over because
of the EU referendum yeah yeah it's very
much so G she does
she's stronger and Maggie no I am German
you're German all right so you're going
Merkel yes it may be we care we can
choose and be are for for terrorism me I
really you'd beat you'd vote to respect
yes yes yes why you why do you think
she's wunderbar is she's so tough yeah
yeah as we like it inspired by these
shores Wordsworth famously wrote about
wandering lonely as a cloud if the Lib
Dems can't hold on to at least some of
their leave voters in their remaining
clutch of seats Tim Farron might well
end up wandering pretty lonely himself
in the next parliament Lois could all
Sky News Windermere